e
um we'll get started
um uh yesterday worked really good for
me to find out which bills people care
about and then we could talk about them
um so just for the audience but most of
them everybody was here yesterday but
that um every bill
is going the the motion is either
recommended or not recommended for
future legislation but they took away
the recommended with Amendment we don't
have that option anymore so therefore um
every bill has to be that we have right
now has to be perfect ready for prime
time for us to recommend for future
legislation which of course none of them
would be that's why they were intered
them studied in the first place so um
what we are going to say and I do want
to do as a chairman of this committee is
that these are some issues that we need
to drill down we need to understand more
we need to do more homework on and so
that we will have subcommittees and I'm
going to tell you right now even before
we talk about anything that Senate Bill
353 relative to the autism spectrum and
1571 uh the glucose are two bills that
we are definitely going to be doing
subcommittees going forward on so the
only thing we'll be discussing today is
who's going to serve on that
subcommittee um going forward but um
other than those two is there any bill
here that someone um would like to share
otherwise we'll just go right to uh okay
yes yes sir what oh you're a rep
so yes I'm not sure I know your name so
sor
the liquor yes yes well that just we'd
like to yeah we'd like to have you speak
on that one okay uh anybody
sir hi Will Walker Hollis New Hampshire
uh I'm here to support s sp353 and the
subcommittee yeah so what what other
information would you need uh before
going into when when we get into the
subcommittee it's going to be a
free-for-all discussion okay thank you
thank you very much right so just show
up for when that happens okay all right
uh so every that's that's it okay so why
don't we um why don't we why don't you
come up and do the liquor the liquor one
thank thank you good morning gim hunt
members um I appreciate a couple minutes
to to revisit this um Bill uh so
um the original bill that was submitted
uh I'm so sorry um so that would be
House Bill
1621 um requiring the uh state liquor
source to distribute information um uh
on on alcohol um use disorder I don't
think that's the official title sorry I
don't have it in front of me um I I
wanted to comment I know the bill was
sent to interim study and in the the
final session before um that vote uh uh
Chief armaganian and the the the
chairman of uh the State Liquor
Commission basically agreed to create a
voluntarily create a um a video to run
in all of the state liquor stores on a
on a loop um and committed to doing that
within six months and that uh has come
to pass um it was uh it was I think a a
great outcome for for the bill that I
had submitted even though it wasn't the
outcome that I had uh intended in the
legislation so I wanted to make sure it
was clear that this I see um and and and
uh to commend chairman hunt he original
his original reaction to me when we
first discussed this was love to do this
without legislation um and so something
significant happened without legislation
so um thanks for sort of sparking that
um you know the video that was created
was was I think quite good it was
empowering it was hopeful it was
non-stigmatizing it was action oriented
um you know I hope I hope it makes a
difference and I I just wanted to say
the the best part of that video for me
is the last line of that video which
says this message brought to you by the
New Hampshire State Liquor Commission
you know it's a mission it's a it's a
message about seeking help and the
availability of help coming directly
paired from the groups that that uh from
from the the agency within the state
that distributes liquor and I feel like
both of those um phenomenon the distri
the the use of of alcohol in our society
and the inevitable problems that a small
portion of people have with alcohol you
know are really inextricably paired
together and I love I love seeing that
we are for the first time time sort of
finding ways to use our state's
connection directly with the people who
you know would be coming in possibly on
the most frequent basis to to um you
know to make sure that they know um that
help is available and where to get it um
you know I I I will end with saying I
hope it's a first step um
because I feel like there's there's a
great opportunity you know there there's
many people who work trying to Market in
general these Concepts to the public
trying to find the people who need them
when we have this opportunity of folks
coming through the door um of state
liquor stores on a routine basis and
that's probably the vast majority of
those that need to be reached um you
know i' I'd love to think that there
could be more obviously the bill that I
brought forward had the concept of
something that people take out of the
store you know be it on the back of
receipts or or many of the ideas that
sort of were floated on a very lowc cost
low um effort basis just to make sure
that it's not just those 30 seconds
while that person you know is in the
store for uh you know to purchase
something but that something will go
home and even if it gets thrown away a
100 200 times maybe one day they will
see it pick it up you know think about
these these Quest you know these issues
and and and take action because re
really that's the goal for me is you
know getting people to recognize the
problem and and Avail themselves of the
existing resources um again I think it
you know as was discussed very low cost
um to to the state to implement some of
these things and and doesn't even
require sort of an active role of anyone
within the liquor stores to to achieve
so I'm hoping that there could be a way
forward for this um you know and again
unclear uh still to this day what does
and doesn't require legislation how much
needs to be done by authorization how
much can be done voluntarily how to lock
in these Concepts I know it's funded by
a grant from outside the state currently
love to see what's been achieved sort of
uh you know be become part of the
operating standard operating procedure
so that that's that's my thought I'm
again very grateful for what happened
and hopeful that uh it's the beginning
of you know a new way forward where you
know I'd love to see our state be sort
of recognized as as one of the states
that is most proactive and most um on
top of this
connection between between alcohol and
um and the inevitable issues so that's
that's my thoughts I'm glad to answer
anything if anyone has has a question I
don't know if that's appropriate y I'd
like to add uh thank you very much
representative I'd like to add that um I
haven't I haven't seen the video in any
of the stores at any time but I do hear
a a public service announcement um on
you know on the on radio playing in you
know in the liquor stores and I think
that is
more effective than the video because
you hear it while you're in the store
and you're not standing in front of a
screen so kudos to the uh Liquor
Commission for doing that as well yep
and I I I visited the store with several
people who are are very interested in
this and and the reaction of all of them
was that that it's very good you know
again I think the most difficult part is
you know you're it's a limited contact
with with someone you know at a time
when they have another agenda which is
to purchase something you know and I'd
love to find a way to extend that but
that that's a great thought thank you
for
that representative Gibbs thank you and
thank you for coming in this morning um
my question uh is about the usefulness
of putting something on the receipts uh
when people buy liquor in the state
liquor stores I know that was a major
part of the discussion during the
original hearing on the bill whether it
was practical how much it would cost and
so forth um but my question is based on
the fact that I've been in a state
liquor store a couple of times um fairly
recently
and uh sometimes the cashier says do you
want the receipt and a lot of the time I
just say no so I don't even see the
receipt at all and even when I take the
receipt I have to tell you it's that
long and so far as I can recall I have
never ever actually looked at it um and
I imagine that's true for most people so
my question is do you still think that
putting something on the receipt would
be
useful thank thanks as that's a great
thought um the way I originally drafted
this bill it left it quite open in terms
of how the liquor stores would
distribute this information and and the
information would include in my in in my
vision of that two parts one is a Ser a
short series of questions to help you
consider whether or not you are someone
who might need help um that's always
step one in someone seeking help is
recognizing it and then the second part
was the referral system you know at the
time it was up and air between 988 and
211 but either of those um you know
mechanisms already exist and the
programs behind it or exist the idea
behind something like receipt and I
totally agree every time I go to CVS I I
leave with you know six feet of paper um
is that the people who most need this uh
are probably coming in on a very
frequent basis you know so the this
won't be one receipt it will be many
many receipts um and it might not be the
person who purchases it it might be a
family member or a friend who picks that
up and says hey you know this this is
something that sounds like you the the
other question is if they don't take the
receipt um you know
there's electronic receipts if they if
if they're distributed that way if
there's not electronic receipts you know
so be it um you know I know there was
some resistance to the idea of including
some sort of a card um there's a couple
other folks here who might have some
ideas of other materials that are that
are very low impact or low low cost that
already exist that could be that could
be utilized to to further lessen the
burden on on the state the idea is just
to put something in someone's hand that
you know with repeated messaging and
repeated use could could lead them to
take
action representative M thank you
chairman ju just a quick question you is
this um video playing in all liquor
stores because I've never seen it and
maybe I'm just not going into the liquor
store enough I I don't know I I won't
comment on the second part um but but uh
um it is it is playing um on all stores
that have screens which is not all
stores from what I understand but um in
the stores that I've visited there there
are multiple screens and it alternates
between sort of promotional um roughly
30 seconds I can see of promotional um
content around sales or other other
items and then it alternates back and
forth to this 30- second um video and
the video does not call out in any way
alcohol specifically it's about you know
reaching out for help in in in the
broader sense um and again I I think
that maybe why I'm I'm speaking here is
that you know I would I would love to
find a way that that content could could
stay with the customer as they as they
leave in a way that gives them other
opportunities to to to
connect representative pusk thank you Mr
chair thank you representative for
bringing this bill uh I live in Dair we
have a new liquor store and uh I took
the opportunity a couple of weeks ago to
spend some time just viewing what's
going on uh I saw the video I was there
for like 15 20 minutes I saw the video
twice M uh and the
audio will be great because it kind of
works into your subconscious whether you
know it or not you're listening to it
and I counted the number of people at
two registers that took receipts over 15
minutes it's three people Y and
everybody was offered them nobody told
accept three people I always take mine
my wife will kill me if I don't uh but
what you brought forward I believe is
working uh from my point of view and uh
with the Liquor Commission and I think
new Futures might have had a little
piece of it uh thank you very much would
you believe and thank thank you for
offering the receipt uh pre-printed
receipt idea as a would you believe
initially on on this um again I'm I'm
totally agnostic to how this content
gets distributed um you know I I think
the receipts were an idea they may be an
idea of a bygone era um you know again
hopeful hopefully we can we can find
ways to further deepen this kind of
collaboration follow up sure just for a
minute thir question thank you Mr and if
you save one life it's worth it thank
more okay uh we'll wrap it up I I I
guess I only have one comment yes and uh
it's related to a different issue which
is the marijuana that this is only
possible because we have a control state
with State liqu Stores also also
completely agree it gives us a
absolutely unique opportunity to go
further than many other states can go in
terms of addressing sort of the known
consequences of alcohol call for small
segment of society that that that
experiences difficulty thanks and I
there there may be a couple other folks
that came today but um if if that's all
all right thank you thank you for your
time y so is anybody else would like to
weigh in and tell how great 1571 turned
down since representative pusk mentioned
new Futures you probably want to tell us
what new futures did for this good
morning my name is Kate fry from new F
uh new Futures I'm so sorry I'm not in
back to school mode I forgot my badge
today I'm very sorry about that I'll be
very brief I want to thank
representative tour for introducing the
legislation and for uh this committee to
helping find uh a non-legislative
solution and particularly for the Liquor
Commission I have to say new Futures uh
didn't have as big a role as the Liquor
Commission and the Department of Health
and Human Services is incorporating the
strong as Granite campaign so that we
know it's evidence-based and that the
messaging is spot on my only request
down the line and it doesn't necessarily
have to be legislation is that we do
think about the sustainability of this
The Liquor Commission was very grateful
to offer this uh to do this but we don't
know if that will be forever or so I I
think it'd be helpful to see the
effectiveness and consider this in
you could take that up with Finance when
they do their budget yeah I I if
anything I would say we want to expand
it to include 988 make sure have 988 is
being presented so I will I will pass
that on to the commission so uh we G
make a motion no we're gonna we'll take
everything on one day when we bam them
all out some of the time okay that's it
for 1571 is there any other Bill other
than 350 3 and
1571 or 1621 anybody else would like to
talk about speak now or forever more
hold your
P
okay all right so let's talk about the
subcommittee for these two bills I
assume you want to be on the
subcommittee these two bills
okay yes you put your mic on please
comment I want to make a I want to make
a
comment uh in researching in doing some
research on the situation with Down
syndrome kids I went to the National
Institutes of Health and also the CDC
and New Hampshire has 1800 a population
of 1,800 people with Down Syndrome
that's the total population we get about
20 Down syndrome kids a
year that's the total we are not talking
about a huge number of
people of the kids that have Downs
according to the National Institutes of
Health 16% % have also a a co-diagnosis
of
autism that's 16% another 16% have
autism like symptoms in other words they
have symptoms but they're not severe
enough to be considered
autistic those are the kids that we
having that are that were having a
problem and also other behavioral issues
the other problem that I saw so the rest
of the Down Syndrome population of young
people and and this adaptive Behavior
kind of things only work for young
people it doesn't work for older people
when we get I mean I can't picture
somebody changing me at all it's too
late for me but you know it only works
for young people so it's not we're not
talking about a large population and I
think it is our responsibility to do
something about these kids and help them
as best we can because if we don't help
them now
when they become adults and they have
not received the proper training or
anything we can do then we're stuck with
a much worse problem and so I think it's
it's very important that we extend this
legislation eventually and get this
covered and the other thing I I've
spoken to uh the medical director of uh
Anthem and and the application of
whether or not there's efficacy re
evolving this kind of Behavioral analys
say it hasn't been updated in quite some
time
and so I'm I'm not clear on how valid
that is you know so and kids are being
turned away and massach and this is
another Point massachusett has done a
study because they're they're working on
a law very similar to ours and it comes
out to about 18
cents so for 18
cents it's a very good bang for the buck
so I'm hoping that we can put together
some kind of legislation that works when
you say turned away who who's turning
away I we have someone here who can talk
about that there are there are kids who
are not being covered under uh their
insurance is not covered they applied
for the insurance the insurance didn't
cover it got it okay and as I say if you
don't cover them now we're going to have
a much worse problem later because the
kids aren't going to get
better
okay all right so we will um I will
appoint who else would like to be on the
subcommittee
else I will be running the subcommittees
and two it's right now we're right now
two uh well I would just have to find
another Republican so but you can
obviously show up you mean subcommittees
does not
limit you know you know obviously there
will be print in the calendar when you
urge everyone to to show up and be
informed
so Mr chair the other uh the liquor
bills that are at the bottom of the list
yeah um could we just um what happened
to these bills I mean they're interm
studies so we no longer need them if
we're not discussing them or I I don't
know I don't remember what the outcome
was yeah
right
uh we well I mean I guess like in I like
1374 that was representative Sullivan's
Bill okay yep yep
all right and then the consumption of
alcohol and performance areas are we
done with the other yeah right so right
now it's going to be hunt Spear willo
and
walz okay so yes we're done with that so
now we're just uh going
through
um okay well the terms of relative
oversight Liquor Commission funding and
repealing the Liquor Commission fund is
no I'm good with that does anybody want
to do that
okay didn't think so okay um 1582 oh
relative to allowing for consumption of
alcohol and artist performance areas we
did address that in a different build
yeah we did address that okay yeah and
then uh that was us where we killed we
killed several birds with one stone okay
and then the labeling of uh
THC where the the last one okay um was
do we have a similar bill as that Dad
Dad got taken care of a different
legislation the um it it is labeled now
it was it was about the delta8 and Delta
9 yeah you know what's did it yeah it
got it stuck in they got stuck in in a
different Bill and so they are believe
you me anything that says Senate bill
you know they tenant took care yeah but
yes the sunset was appeal exactly that's
was and uh then cannabis I just assume
there'll be other people putting new
so whether we this committee will will
get it anyway
so we we'll get it hopefully but you
never know they might send it to another
dag who knows but I Haven done that but
okay is everybody else feel comfortable
that the rest of them are going to be
not recommended we got these two and so
we're good thank you all for attending
and uh pay attention to the house
calendar and we these bills will show up
there and I'm missing my gavel but we're
a Jour oh representative Gibs yes uh
sorry uh could you tell us who's on the
subcommittees
uh yeah well I I didn't bring my notes
in from yesterday but uh no I just meant
the two for today to today's hunt Spear
bullo and Walsh for both of them yes
thank
me okay what was the number of the
second Bill other than the autism was a
353 these two health insurance mandates
and that's why I'm putting them into one
subcommittee because they're both health
y
okay oh it's open okay off the Record
question you want
to yeah all right we're move to a journ